okay hi everyone welcome to another
wolen language design review part of our
language completeness and consistency
series and uh we're going to start on
item two here because we're still
waiting for some people for item
one uh okay one argument form of monitor
a really useful
thing
um
so right this is basically monitor of
map and things like that right
correct um let's take a look
here oh that's really useful super super
duper
useful I'm not sure I totally like the
display there but but this is super
useful okay so now what's the issue with
this so so I mean there's one real issue
and one just review of
the um you know you know of the design
so I have I have a question how deep
does it go so I assume that the monitor
only looks at the function that is
directly wrapped around is that correct
correct correct that ispp point that's
the type wrapping section and that was
the original spec you gave us and that's
what we've implemented so but just I
think it makes
sense yeah I think this is fine this is
absolutely want to double check yeah I
think that's a okay I think that's the
only reasonable way in other words
monitor is kind of like an adverb of the
of the action it's kind of like do it I
mean you know the alternative which I
don't like as much is a rapper monitor
in other words something like this where
we say you know a monitored table blah
blah
blah but I mean and conceivably that's
an alternative form that we could have
but I like the putting the monitor
around there just like we put an echo
around there I like it much better okay
I mean like in another words if we put
an
echo around this whole thing well no
it's a different thing because it's
because that because the the return
value is is sort of the global thing for
all of it okay next up what what are the
issues here so the the main issue is
what to
do so I'm sorry you cut out for a second
the main issue is what what to do in the
failure case so normally a monitor just
evaporates away but if we did that in
the error case then we would evaluate
the input twice and you know get all the
side effects twice and doubled messages
so notate away and other possibility is
I'm sorry I didn't hear that you kept
cutting out here so it says it again so
uh one Poss
return evaluated completely with you
know monitor still stuck there or to
return a failure object and and I we've
implemented both for you to sort of okay
what what is the cause of the failure
what's the cause of a failure so in this
in this case you gave
invalid right you gave invalid limits
right you gave a list times G as the
iterator and right table would not table
bared
right gave an invalid
table well what does the table itself
return it returns unevaluated right
correct so I think the monitor should
just return around it and it's still
unevaluated yeah I think that sorry um
uh you were cutting out a bit the thing
is the typically monitor adds something
on the side and then just runs the code
as you as you give it yeah so in this
case it would just give the the
unevaluated table but in this case we
need to do some code transformation to
actually do the
monitoring so we we this is like a
different different return like
um if you if you monitor with two
arguments you would get an evaluated
table not unevaluated
monitor but with with the automatic
one we cannot return anal table because
we've modified that and and and and
returning tabl
why I don't understand I don't
understand I don't understand you you've
you've modified the code but the code
fails you determined that the table
didn't manage to T tabulate itself so to
speak exactly okay you've presumably
stored what the code was before you
started doing it yeah and yeah is there
is right but if we did that then it
would evaluate then a second time
outside the monitor so you'd get get
doubled messages doubled side effects
and I'm sorry why why why because we
didn't really evaluate table we
evaluated the modified version with the
progress monitoring so that expression
was never flagged as evaluated well it's
not just that right it's that
the so we we we we try to evaluate the
thing and then we're like oh we're in
trouble we can't do this and if we then
return the table right then the function
has returned right has evaluated non
so infinite evaluation takes
over and uh but okay so the statement
Julio made namely the table that is
returned here is not flagged as having
been evaluated because it has been
reconstituted therefore it will be
evaluated
again
right I mean if monitor in this
situation didn't evaluate its argument
for some reason yeah that's a
mess okay hold on let me think about
this for a
second I mean the situation is something
has gone very
wrong and most of the time this is going
to be code where you're just going to
rerun the code the return value of the
code is largely
irrelevant see I'm worried about about
okay
I mean I think if people are using the
confirm and Clos framework and things
like that properly then the generation
of a failure object is not so
terrible words do you understand what
I'm saying what I'm saying is this isn't
a thing which is going to evaluate it to
itself and treat it as an object this is
very much a piece of code and the piece
of code you don't usually look at the
return value of the
code am I making
sense I'm sorry at least for me you
could in and out a bit so I didn't quite
catch C can you maybe could you maybe
dial in your audio some some other way
so that we can I can
try okay and I assume somebody
communicated with s men that there's
some problem right did somebody do that
please
hello I can do that because I can
complain for myself
too okay do we have a project manager
here who is it yes Addison so okay so
why doesn't Jeremy go and do make the
complaint just so we make sure somebody
knows this is a
problem
okay all
right so did you understand what I said
do I have to repeat what I said welcome
Zoom enter your meeting what are you
doing followed by P hey hey hey hey mute
that
okay no I see your point Stephen like we
I mean we have been pushing failure a
lot with the the whole confirm and close
um system I think more comfortable with
failure but the point that I'm
making if this is going to be used if
monitor is going to be used primarily in
code right
yeah I mean you could also interactively
do
or like around something like you do
input form or something like
that in some interactive
way I don't like this very
much right this so I you know I was
switching to to phone audio to hopefully
improve my situation but obviously I
didn't hear some segment of s sounds
terrible you might want to use some
microphone configuration it's different
but at least we can hear you okay so uh
you sounds like you're in a
cave okay um I will try to find a
different headset um but in a minute I
don't think your headset is connected I
think you're not going through your
headset sounds like speaker phone just
make sure the headset is actually being
used
okay
um the
uh no come on I'm just saying that this
is where we got stuck
we don't like could you try to get your
audio so that we can actually hear you
properly how's
this uh no yeah at least low noise it's
it's very quiet but it's low
Noise Okay um is there some no no now we
can hear you I mean you speak loudly so
it's okay
okay
um Okay so
yes you got stuck here because so what
would we like it to do okay so let's
imagine what other examples are there
let's try something here so let's say
it's
table
wz okay that's going to give an error
right so now we
say uh SL slash input
form well SL slash I don't know what we
some other form SL SL
framed okay I mean that's the best thing
is that it just returns unevaluated with
the monitor wrapped around
it
so and the issue
is that because this is code I mean this
may need internal code that just you
know tags
it somehow so that this doesn't fail
again you see what I'm saying I I think
this is the desirable
outcome and in terms of testing this out
we could test it out with double error
messages and things like that if
necessary but I mean the other
possibility I mean there is a case isn't
there where we wrap a
hold when something went horribly
wrong I think the only example I can
think of is the recursion limit
iteration Limit Oh yeah yeah right which
we've now stopped doing right right well
we now do terminative valuation
right I don't like this so much because
I think this
is let's see let me argue this again let
me argue against myself for a
second the point is that like Echo
monitor will evaporate if it did its job
job
correct
correct so the argument is if it didn't
do its job you might as well feed a
failure object in because it's because
it's blown up anywhere I mean even if
what you returned was monitor of table
you'd still have something that your
outer code was going to choke
on am I making
sense did you understand what I said yes
right I mean basically this is you know
basically this is the case where you
gave something where the thing you gave
it can't actually evaluate so you know
we could try to return that unevaluated
thing um but again you know we'd have to
solve the time stamp problem or we could
just return a failure object saying well
you did something we don't know I think
that's the right thing to do I think
this is ridiculously wordy I think
because I think we should just say
um
uh I mean do we know it's just UNM
monitorable or do we know that it's say
uh well we know why don't we say monitor
look why don't we say monitored
evaluation failed for blah blah
blah see the word I think that would be
monitored
evaluation failed for blah I don't
really like that tag why do we need that
tag do we have to have that tag can we
have a custom failure object or do we
not want to do
that no we we can we can put whatever we
want there right failure all failure
objects have a tag right but do they
display it do they always display it
like
this
I let I think so I think so that's kind
of like the the message name
basically
okay well then so sometimes there you
know
more what does in mean yeah invalid this
this
Pro I'm looking The Interpreter says
interpretation failure I could like uh
camel case I could say monitor
failure where up here as a tag
tag if you look at at the page for
failure the first example you you see is
interpreter and his interpretation
failure interpret sorry for interpreter
you said normally the tags are more C
case I I didn't notice this or I would
have commented on it but yeah if you you
know you see I see I see interpretation
failure I could say monitoring failure
right you know right it can for an
interpreter it can be like
interpretation failure restriction
failure then why don't we do this why
don't we just say message message and
then just give see I'm worried that
these expressions are going to be long
and things like
that makes sense yeah so we could just
say message and then table blah blah
blah tag monitor
failure now do we have to give the
function name here because interpreter
isn't giving the function name
there no no we don't I typically add the
function name when I produce custom
failures for like
so let's not do it here tring it but you
monitor fa clear right I right I mean
the only right the only other thing we
could do is if we had both the function
and then we could have the expression
wrapped in hold as another thing and
then it would be beneath the plus sign
right he added exactly one thing beyond
the tag which is why it's showing all
three if you added two or more things
then there would be right it would only
show the message and the tag and
everything else would be so I assume
that this gets shortened if this thing
is mega long
right yeah there are ways to shorten it
yes we can shallow it
yes
um I reckon we should just put the
expression here and then say tag uh
monitor
failure
and that's so the message is just the
expression no text that's what I'm
saying just like enter a valid number
it's not a message that you see what I'm
saying that that's a just the message is
just the
expression
okay I I don't understand I don't
understand that at all I mean right and
enter a valid number is is Right some
right that has know it's telling you
something about the input but it's not
the inut right okay listen we could say
evaluation failed
for to what I'm saying because that's
what that's what really happened
right evaluation failed for and then
monitor
failure
okay put this
place
okay all right okay so this is wonderful
let's look at which functions it covers
so
far and we know
that know that there are a few more that
we can easily
add okay I forgot about cool map but
yeah
there's
wow we got to do better than
this well right I mean
normally right map itself is TP you know
is not the slow thing it's the
evaluation after the map that's slow
right because map just inist the
function in the so you know we if you
have a a fast quickly evaluating
function then you know adding all these
extra evaluations to create pretty boxes
and okay I got a question I got a
question monitor presumably map
presumably knows how big the thing it's
mapping over is
correct not really really well yes it
does by the time map is running it knows
this thing as a length 2 million
list well in in in in the case where
it's
uh you know well if it's doing flat list
sure in the CA in the case where it's a
flat list sure but you know if you're
mapping you know over a complicated
expression at level Infinity then it
doesn't know right right okay in the
flatlist case let me make a comment
you're wrapping things around those
elements to you know record monitors
right that's how you're doing it
presumably you're you're sewing
something or something like that from
different elements to say update the
monitor correct yeah I'm just injecting
an expression that grows at at every
step well I understand but so what I'm
going to suggest is this if you see
you've got a list of length 2 million
Don't Spray it at every point you don't
need to nobody cares about whether it's
the 100,000 200 you know whatever it is
you get what I'm saying but but this I'm
not sure that this will help you because
the the thing is the AOC compilation
will still be broken because I have to
put like I don't know if if the a
compilation can can it deal with an if
for example I have to do some experiment
I have to do some experiment find out
let's find out ask the people involved
in autoc
compilation right because what I'm
suggesting is if in fact the evaluation
of the monitor thrower is slow by the
time you've got 2 million elements in
the list you're mapping over you don't
need to
put you know you don't need to wrap the
monitor thrower around every element
right you don't ex you don't need that
level of grity if you're mapping over
two milum elements ideally the function
is going to be quite fast well yeah but
but but I mean in particular I think 1%
you know if you no completion levels to
1% you're in good
shape see what I'm saying MH now that
means that if if you do that if you
spray like that you do not want to
report element 100 out of 2 million
element 200 out of 2 million you want to
report 1% 2% whatever so nobody can look
because if it turned out one of those
elements was a killer you see what I'm
saying we're not going to
know do you understand what I'm saying
so if it says 3% and it freezes at 3%
you have some idea what happened but you
don't want to fake it and freeze at 200
or so 300 or whatever it is make sense
yeah
yep so and I have to check because I'm
not actually using map to do this I'm
using map index set because map index
set tracks the all right okay okay
okay I hope that map index has the same
level of optimization as you got to go
check that you got to go work with
people who are involved in that Tom
whoever it is and and and um you know
make sure it works but let's get this
one argument monitor into the system
because I think it's super
useful okay okay so
one consideration um I refactor the code
like recently to
basically have a Helper and implement
the addition of every function using
this
helper um can I put are you ask
impementation Detail no no no no no wait
wait a second let me finish so this
helper basically allows you to add more
functions that will basically work with
the one argument monitor that's can I
release that to the functional pository
yes okay good
idea this way you can you know extend
the framework as as you
please yeah I mean I think we should do
I don't think anybody should need to use
it right well obviously internal people
will just do it directly with the
lowlevel stuff that yeah this is
useful
us well and also users might want to
teach monitor that's a really good point
that's a really good point
yes now the tight wrapping
business one day we should not need that
one day what should happen is you say
monitor for the whole thing and then it
should sort of flash up monitoring this
monitoring that monitoring the other
thing you see what I'm
saying so you'd get like a sequence of
yes and I mean a sequence in time of
panels for each monitor yes yes this is
a nested problem in general yeah I could
have a table with inside a nest and and
this would fire two two monitoring
things at the same time this is wrong
where where the hell did you get those
words from where's the word iterating
coming
from uh wait a second can can you EV I
thought I fix most of those now it
should can you do with with map uh I had
custom words but now I I think I replace
them with like just monitoring this or
that what is what what is map
saying the the other
example oh yeah okay the input directly
below he's asking you to evaluate the
input directly below
yeah I don't like that I don't like that
that's not what it said it not didn't
say map space peren
pause
um okay let's decide on something yeah I
know I know I know I know I
know um I think it should just say
evaluating and then brackets map of the
this comma dot dot
dot
probably do you understand what I'm
saying do I need to write it out right
and and obviously the function will need
to be shortened in case somebody decides
to write a five paragraph pure function
in the first
argument yeah that's what I would do dot
dot dot there and then I would
say this is
wrong that's not right that doesn't make
sense processing eight what do we do for
other cases because this is it's not
processing eight of 20 elements because
that suggests it's doing all of those
it's done eight it's got more to go
right or it's doing the eighth
one no he say processing 1 2 3 four up
to 20 no no no no no no no I understand
but it say it should say processing
element 8 of 20 if that's what it
means
okay making sense yeah yeah processing
eight of 20 means it's doing eight all
together out of 20 which is
wrong that's you're dealing with a
non-native English speaker be kind uh
sorry sorry
I Julio is so good in his English that I
figure he knows it perfectly thank you
Stephen but no no rereading this it
makes sense um yeah should be processing
element 8 out of 20 yeah yeah okay and I
just wasn't reading these carefully
enough because I was so wowed by the pro
by the panels themselves I forgot to
actually read the text carefully so I
I'll take some ownership too okay all
right okay this by by the way this I'm
um I mean looks at the at the whole
expression so if you have like a nested
the you like random real 3 four 56 and
you upap at at the final level it will
tell you the the product of all those
Dimension
fine I assume that that's fine yeah
because counting the exact amount of and
depends on the it takes into into
account the level so if you upap at
every level is is the sum of all the
products at every level yeah this thing
is so wonderful that the fact that it
isn't perfect yet is okay I I think we
just have to start using it but make
sure the speed problem is solved and and
I I do think going to something that
isn't tight wrapping in the end is
important
okay then I have a question for that
that I um I have here like literal or
um um Dynamic scoping for the
monitoring like do we do know if you
have table of Nest literally in the
monitor we we monitor both but if you
have monitor monitor of like function
and function inside is calling other
things do we still prop propagated or no
I understand you're asking is it dynamic
or lexical exactly modular
block I think block will be the best
case I
think okay then I have to
study well I mean we could start off
with the first one I I don't know I
don't know what it's going to feel like
see what I'm saying yeah I I kind of
feel like what we want is you say I've
got this operation the the one issue
there
is let's say you monitor something and
it goes into internal code of ours and
it's monitoring some totally random
weird thing inside and it's
incomprehensible to people right because
it says you know evaluating fold pair
list or whatever and it's like I don't
have a full pair list what the heck is
talking
about uh I could respect
reprotected yes I you should but I mean
I think that's you should anyway
but I think that may not be enough and I
think I think it may be less confusing
to do it
lexically okay it's also easier so I
I'll start with the Leal impementation
start with that take a look and see if
we like it or not maybe we don't like it
maybe we do let's
see
um okay
uh all
right think that's everything in this
section so and Roger is here so we can
talk about okay all right are you are
you you're staying in this form of audio
that's fine all right let's tackle
binomial you know I what is that what
chap Nam morotti or something who was
the the person with A Treatise on the
binomial theorem
Professor Mariotti is that right in the
Sherlock Holmes books I I believe so yes
okay well we need we we've we've been
sent many treatises on the binomial
theorem here uh
so right so basically so so if you want
the the history of sort of why things
changed then well let's just talk about
what the main issue is the main issue is
binomials of negative numbers negative
integers chain at some point and we've
got users who are up in arms about it
right yes yes why did it
change was it just a mistake or is it no
not really well it's it's sort well I I
I think it was a wrong decision but I it
was just a simple
mistake it was a wrong decision we
should just fix it yeah it was a wrong
decision but well can we can Stephen I
you know I I I actually put some thought
so can I actually pres what the issues
are speech yes so uh right so basically
this started with so you know binomial
of NN Auto evaluates to one which is
sort of you know combinatorics or if you
just look at the natural definition over
the complexes you know it's one
everywhere except where we have PS I.E
negative integers um yes and so we used
to give zero which was probably the
correct def decision but zero for what
so I'm sorry for for binomial of minus
you know minus K minus minus n minus n
where N is a positive integer so
binomial of minus one minus one would
give zero binomial of minus 2 minus two
would give zero Etc um and then we tried
to do some antic continuation and that
was a stupid stupid
idea no okay that is not what happened
so B so then Bill gosper complained well
binomial of NN is one but binomial of
minus one minus one is zero so you're
inconsistent and
um and um you know I think uh what he
was saying was that you know binomial of
n comma n shouldn't Auto
evaluate and you know
Sasha uh well I mean I think did Sasha
did try this it broke all sorts of
things um and so Sasha came up with this
symmetric
definition um which H you know preserves
that um identity there sort of in the
middle of the screen um which identity
this identity here no so if you scroll
down to the full
simplify then that identity is preserved
everywhere in the complex plane s I'm
not seeing a full simplify which which
Full
simplify uh like after the third bullet
point in that section that my and it's
in traditional
form yeah
so next one oh there I
see um so that identity is preserved
everywhere in the complex plane which
means we can Auto
evaluate and um yeah but that does that
give the correct answer for binomial of
minus one minus
one so you could argue what the correct
answer is okay so really we made up some
way of of of avoiding the problem of
having binomial of NN evaluate so this
is again the standard problem of generic
versus you know if I say n / n we say
it's one even though exactly exactly
right which is sort of sort of my
position it's like yeah the binomial
this inconsistency is like saying well X
overx shouldn't Auto evaluate to one
well and C that does cause the
occasional problem but you know you gain
so much from that that the people who
need to worry about that case just need
to be made to worry about that
case and so right and basically the and
Don's biggest complaint which I I think
is correct is the if you scroll down to
the asymmetric definition then um you
know defining it to be one instead of
zero which you know is consistent with
various other ways of looking at the
problem but it violates the Pascal
identity that's the second equation in
the asymmetric question right that if if
you if you if you plug in n equals z and
k equals z into Pascal's identity then
you get that binomial of minus oneus
zero isn't the obvious suggestion
binomial of NN is one but binomial of
specific integer minus one minus one is
zero yes correct and that that's
basically was at the end of the treaties
that that was going to be my end the
vendor's recommendation possibly we
preserve a system option for bill gosper
so that he can turn off the auto
evaluation
and be happy um so the way the way it's
currently implemented in the Prototype
build all that auto evaluation is turned
off so when we turn it back on we can
leave a system option for you know Bill
gosper to to turn on if he really cares
um but basically we we think the most
useful thing is we want the generic
evaluation but specific guys give the
thing that preserves I I will point out
that what Sasha did does preserve
Pascal's identity everywhere except z0
so it's not like he did something
completely crazy no uh but it does
obviously wrankle certain people and you
know given given
unnecessary
yes it seems useful that Pascal's
triangle if you continue Pascal's
triangle outside of the region where the
triangle is you know the coordinates of
the triangle that it gives
zero which is what this would do it
gives it gives zero to the top left it
does not give zero to the top right
which is what you want if you want I
actually have that in my little section
about uh a note on Pascal's triangle so
what Sasha's definition did is give an
alternating binomial theorem to the top
left whereas the the old definition
gives zeros to the top left but the top
right continues to extend which is what
you want for binomial series you know I
think that Don Don is overstating the
case a little bit I I mean agreed that
it's wrong but it's he's overstating the
case a bit about how wrong it is because
you know what people really care about
is the top right where you go to
binomial series and very few people care
about the top left where nobody really
does anything but does anybody know
whether did Don's books assume this do
we know
has he made this assumption for like you
know 50 years or something of what what
happens for negative binomials and if so
why did he make that
assumption anybody know I um I believe
or has it never shown up in his books I
think we could look in concrete
mathematics yes yeah that's most likely
place the
textbook yes I mean really the primary
definition only defines it for the
triangle so to speak yeah
I know everything else but everything
but I don't know what kind of
combinatorial identities are nicely this
is what I'm a little bit concerned about
that we should just check that you know
the zero definition sort of if it
beautifully sort of aligns with
combinatorial definitions great if it's
like oh well whoops uh whatever it's a
little bit more questionable but I I
agree look Sasha's custom definition
does not seem like something doesn't
seem like the right idea I mean he was
trying to extend
it you know had a clever solution for
extending right he was trying to find
perfect consistency between generic
evaluation and and numerical evaluation
which I don't think is going to work I
mean right here's a question that I have
how many other cases do we have where a
generic
simplification VI is is violated by
specific cases do we have any idea in
the special function well or in the in
the discrete math domain how many other
situations we have like that we don't
know but here's an example of something
so when we did the discret calculus
project one reason to do that was that
Victor returned his hyp geometrics they
were completely undefined at the integer
points where you actually wanted to
evaluate it they all blew up you I mean
they typically blew up to to what I'm
saying it wasn't generically
wrong just wrong at every point you
cared about
yes yes exactly that's funny that is
kind of funny um okay well how many
more of those I mean so that's a gamma
function type thing and and yes he he is
assuming this in uh in uh um right he
says explicitly that symmetry fails for
negative integers and we want zeros in
on pages 156 and 157 of concrete
mathematics so so there is a certain
argument that we should have a function
symmetric binomial that does the
symmetric definition so I you know one
of the ideas I don't know I think I
presented it last time or or we talked
about it is to have like a c
binomial
um well wait a minute wait a minute
that's the case that that's the generic
case the case that Don doesn't want is
the symmetric binomial right right right
right but but since we don't have that
now right so we want to reintroduce the
K binomial no we don't want to do that
don't want to do that we want to change
our generic binomial but I I think in
the in the general principle that things
are named after people they shouldn't be
named after maybe we should name the
definition that P says is wrong after
him but see K also has an opinion so K
changed the the sign of I think Sterling
S1 you know because he has a different
combinatorial definition
yes whereas the Sterling numbers are you
know these alternating and he has a
different
definition which we don't have is that
correct which we don't have okay well
maybe it's the k Sterling but that's a
that's a that's a battle for another day
okay I think symmetric binomial makes
sense as as a system level function yeah
I think it's a little bit pedantic but I
think it's
useful
okay anybody else want to comment on
that yeah but uh so we are uh so we just
need a plan for 141 uh what plan for 141
is with changing binomial yes exactly
that once we agree on that the symmetric
B is definitely a good idea yes okay
fine so there's a bunch of stuff cleanup
work for us to do because our yeah
discret calculus stuff will return it
relies on this definition well it if we
don't touch the generic case then we are
fine if we touch the generic case yes
there'll be a lot of breakage so
question do we touch I I told you
binomial of n comma n returns one great
then then we are fine that's it but
binomial of minus one minus one like X
overx doesn't do the same thing as the
generic case perfect that's all I want
yeah okay but then symmetric binomial is
the thing that correctly you know that
that that has the definition where it
will return what is it returning for for
the for the negative integers it would
return one rather than
yeah yes okay and let me just check one
other thing Q binomial I think is
consistent with the new definition of
binomial is that correct when Q binomial
degenerates to binomial it's now
agreeing with binomial which it wasn't
before that is correct I didn't even
think of that I should have thought of
that yeah that's important right that
that is something Ian and I checked so
okay good good so what about things like
Pock hammer and so on I don't know what
what other things there are in the
constellation around
binomial and whether they're
consistent well there's factorial power
and Pock
Hammer um right we should just check
whether those in that in some generic
case should they simplify to binomial or
symmetric binomial I don't
know or maybe they don't simplify to
binom don't Auto simplify I mean maybe
we can think about the function expand
rules okay yes okay
Auto evaluate yeah
right
okay okay let's make this change I mean
that that was we should have done this a
bit earlier I mean I I thanks to our
vocal users for having vociferously
complained because so apparently chat
GPT told K that binomial is not defined
outside of the triangle which I think is
sort of correct
who
knows and it right and it also said that
Mathematica gives zero which used to be
true
but wasn't and will be true again but
wasn't that the time that Chad jpt made
the assertion well okay but that's you
know if you what was it it was um I mean
these people who Who quote things to me
where saying Chad gbt as Xyz like this
is true it's just the No No No but
people do that serious ly know that's
the shocking thing yes it's some well
you did hear the case about those
lawyers who sub I did yes all right okay
so are we we done with this item yep yep
okay good stuff send out a message when
when it's um when it's handled um okay
let's let's try and quickly get through
the other items in this agenda people
who were here only for binomial can drop
as I believe what happened to whatever
happened to Professor marotti in the
[Music]
end I don't know I mean right he pushed
he pushed Holmes off the cliff but then
magically came back so at some later
point and I don't know what ever
happened to Mor arti after that point
okay okay does anybody know if there's
any particular content assigned to his
Trea on the binom theorem it would be it
would be interesting if he had a
discussion of negative binomials anyway
no matter um than okay seal
okay let's come to this letter counts
right you sent an email saying why
doesn't this work and I pointed out well
I can think of at least two obvious
definitions for what this works means
and so I'm not entirely
convinced we should adopt either one but
if we do we should adopt one okay so so
the issue is letter counts not of a
single string but of a list of strings
correct
what did I think it should do or did I
not even say say you you just had a
screenshot of it not working and the
subject line why doesn't this work and I
was like well which of these do you mean
and you didn't
[Laughter]
reply and and I admit that it's not
obvious and that the translation between
these is
messy because I don't think I can just
take this if I say here you know a I
plus to
this it's going to fail right what how
do I do that in fact is there a way to
do that where it assumes makes an
assumption of zero for the things that
don't correspond we should have that
it's a useful
function think you might need to use
Query or something with a you know joint
something like that I'm sorry might do
something like that but it's not like
simple
usage this seems useful to
me
um okay well we can think about that
it's kind of like an association
apply right it's probably plus is
probably going to be the most common
thing there but it's an association
apply where probably by
default
the this
thing that function of no
arguments maybe maybe that's silly is
the default
case because the thing being omitted if
well the function isn't flat all bets
are off but if the function is flat
right and certainly if it's one identity
then you know there's uh there's you
know some uh there's some default value
right for times it would be one Etc
exactly right maybe I miss understanding
what you're trying to do but if you do a
merge of that list of Association and
the second argument is plus does that
work oh let's find out and I might
understanding what you want to do no I
want to add this up assuming zero for
the
um no that didn't
work I want to do this where maybe
there's an additional plus argument you
want Total not
plus
yeah oh right because it it'll feed it
as the list the the all the elements as
a
list well that's reasonable well what
that did that's
reasonable I think that's reasonable
let's put it as an example in the letter
counts documentation and be done with it
for the time being okay and and make
sure that that sorry I mean see whether
we can make sure that the keywords for
merge say things like adding
associations and
things making sense that is I'm sorry
say that again operator of that so you
can do merge total and apply that to the
list of
associations which I think looks even
nicer that's beautiful I mean if it
works let's take a
look magnificent couldn't be
better right fine document and move on
all right I'm going to suggest we
postpone
this this is a naming this is a naming
this discussion so it won't be well
let's just see if it's okay what was
somebody said do you want dot dot dot do
you want letter counts of a list of
strings to give a list of
associations did we actually answer
that I think that would be
desirable is that is is that what
character counts currently does so one
of these
functions
uh it's not documented but it
actually uh does this at least
for yeah so we could make it's not
documented but apparently it does this
so we could make word counts and letter
counts consistent with this behavior and
then actually document
it seems reasonable to me make them
essentially
listable okay and should they should
they be truly listable like arbitrarily
nested or I don't see why we don't just
make them
listable
yep um are they if there oh they may
have multiple arguments and things but
they should be listable on their first
argument I
think
okay okay
uh right this is a function we've
discussed before and we didn't come up
with a name and so well let's just give
it one second here to come up with a
name and if you know sometimes there's
brilliant strikes quickly and
sometimes it's okay
so right so this is the thing that
basically is a head wrapper
to feed the arguments
unevaluated I mean I think that makes
more sense than held arguments arguments
held is kind of a passive thing like
um well yeah I I guess well I mean I I I
I agree that held is better than hold
but I personally would prefer held
arguments
of I don't think that's the right thing
I think it's I think it's passive voice
it's like uh you know reversed of
something right
I mean it's it's like sorry reverse
applied that would be you know reverse
applied
fyx right so this
is I
see right but it but there the the the
the
thing yeah right held applied might
would work or applied
held right but the re the thing that the
the active thing comes first in the
reverse applied right so the it should
be held applied because that's the
the I
see held applied is not the worst thing
in the
world because it goes along with reverse
applied okay I I'm I'm certainly I mean
like I said this is not quite ready to
be evaluated because we're we're
especially not because it holds its
arguments when it evaluates anyway never
mind evaluated in multiple sense senses
yes but yes I I'm certainly okay with
held applied as a name until you know we
review it for real and then you to hold
a space for the function but okay yes
we're we're punning too badly today um
yes seems good to me all right did we
get through the agenda we did get
through the agenda very surprisingly
excellent good work everybody and then
just about an hour so yeah right good
good timing okay all right thanks a lot
guys see you all soon by
bye